hello everyone welcome to the windscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll in
recent years has been a lot of
discussion and controversy about the
idea of scientific racism the use of
scientific data or techniques to
purportedly justify racist policies or
attitudes or or thoughts about other
kinds of human beings
now as soon as i say the phrase
scientific racism and tell you what it
is
hackles get raised right there's going
to be some people listening who say it's
not racism it's just science we're just
doing science we're classifying people
we're purely understanding the world why
are you trying to ruin it by calling it
racism other people are going to say
it's not scientific right this is not
this is pseudoscience this is just a
perversion of science and on either side
people become very emotional very very
quickly i mean even if you're in the
middle you tend to sort of get very wary
about this kind of discourse just
because other people are so passionate
and let's be frank it lowers your
cognitive abilities when your emotional
valence goes way up like that so
whatever feeling you have when i start
talking about this issue i'm doing that
intentionally
savor that feeling get an idea of what
that feeling is because our guest today
paige hardin who's a psychologist at the
university of texas
wants us to move beyond that feeling she
wants to be able to talk about issues
like
genes and dna and how they influence
whether strongly or weekly
life outcomes
your educational attainment what kind of
job you're going to get whether you're
going to get a mental illness become
homeless things like that and the whole
project of relating genetic information
to later life outcomes is very fraught
with the danger that it can be misused
in racist or other discriminatory ways
and what paige wants to do is say that's
no reason not to use it right there's a
sort of counter-reaction that says
therefore
we shouldn't mention dna or genes at all
when we talk about human beings we
should treat every human being equally
and not worry about their genetic
heritage
page's argument is that we if we really
want to make life better for people
if we really want to fight for social
justice in effective ways we need to use
all the information all the knowledge
all the scientific insight we can get
and there's no doubt from the data that
there's a relationship between genes and
outcomes but what we can try to do
is use information we get about that
relationship to bring that kind of
equality to human life that elizabeth
anderson talked about in a podcast a
while back not equality of opportunity
not a quality of outcome but a quality
of dignity treating people in ways that
lets them lead their lives in society
with sort of equal amounts of dignity
for every person and that's something
where understanding how people are
different
even genetically is going to be
important she has a new book out called
the genetic lottery why why dna matters
for social equality the idea of the
lottery being that we don't choose our
dna our dna affects who we grow up to be
but we don't get credit or blame for it
right we shouldn't anyway so how do you
live in a world where people are given
unequal amounts of talents from the
start so i was really happy with how
this podcast came out i think that paige
does a very good job both at explaining
the science and in making the case that
we have to take that science seriously
even if it means that we have emotional
reactions let's look beyond them let's
really think hard about it let's try to
get at the truth that's something we can
all get behind here at mindscape so
let's go
so
[Music]
paige hardin welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you for having me
you have written a book um about uh an
interesting combination of topics right
i mean you have genetics and biology in
there but also psychology sociology
politics and even philosophy you know
political philosophy is is in there so
there's a lot of details i want to go
through them but just so we don't miss
the point i thought it'd be
best to start with a summary
of the point and so i have i have a
quote here from your publisher's website
i guess princeton university press and
then i'll just state it out loud and and
you can comment on what that means it
says here
yeah hardin shows why a refusal to
recognize the power of dna perpetuates
the myth of meritocracy
and argues that we must acknowledge the
role of genetic luck if we are ever to
create a fair society
all right that's it that's big stuff is
that accurate that is big stuff
uh you can leave it to publishers to put
it in i know
right in very in very dramatic ways um
but it's not wrong that i i do think
that is the point of the book so
so i'm trying to describe both
the science of behavioral genetics um
but also trying to think about what does
it mean how can we make sense of it
why are people uncomfortable with it
and
why our discomfort from with it can in
fact actually get in our way if we're
worried about um
more equal policies and interventions
right so i guess the
background to this is that on the one
hand there's just science i mean we're
figuring things out with uh biology and
sociology but on the other hand there's
a history of misuse of these kinds of
ideas so there's a tendency to
either continue to misuse it or to say
we shouldn't use it at all because it
would be misused and you're trying to go
against both of those tendencies
yes well i mean i guess i would slightly
disagree with you which is that i never
feel like there is in reality just
science there's always science in
context scientists are always
people
who are
coming into the scientific enterprise
with their own sets of preconceptions
and ambitions and motivations and our
interests as scientists don't come out
of nowhere
and i think that's more or less
important for different fields but i
think particularly when we're talking
about research that's connecting
dna genetic differences between people
to
socially valued behaviors and
psychological characteristics so things
like intelligence or things like how far
someone goes in school
um there is this
history which i think most people are
somewhat familiar with of how that
research has been
appropriated and misappropriated um
historically but i think even continuing
today
and so
um in many camps in psychology and then
the other you know in the social
sciences there's been the pendulum
swinging in the opposite direction of
saying
um this has been so historically
um
intertwined
with
people who are trying to kind of allege
the inferiority or superiority of some
people that we really need to kind of
avoid this work entirely but there's um
you know there's a scholar that i quote
in the book that says there's there's no
way to study the genetics of something
like intelligence without being racist
or classist um and i disagree with that
perspective too and so
um in many ways uh the book is trying to
um unravel or disengage
um the science from the politics in
which it's been entwined for such a long
period of time
yeah no i i'm very much on board here i
mean i think that uh you're completely
right in your uh
amendment to the way that i said that
there is just science i mean there's
never just science completely 100 agreed
that's a very important point especially
in this context uh
but you know it's it's also there's this
human tendency to not want to balance
two things right to say that you know to
just go to extremes and say one thing or
the other so if you're talking about
genetics at all you're a racist and
that's a caricature but there are people
who are pretty close to that attitude
and and we should be reaching out to
them and saying no look you know here we
can learn new things about the world
right and and use them to make the world
a better place because refusing to learn
them is not going to change the world is
that fair
i think that's fair i mean i think for
people
you know my personal strategy is when
people
really object to the idea
of
doing this type of work at all and by
this work i mean connecting dna
differences between people dna sequence
variation
to
um what are ultimately social
behaviors and social phenotypes social
characteristics
um
is to remember that often those
objections are coming from
um a very real place of their own lived
experiences with racism and classism um
with being familiar with the with the
history of it
um and so i think
particularly for people from
marginalized communities they're coming
into this work with a very different
kind of set of priors about the
cost-benefit analysis
um
a major goal of the book then for me is
to try to
take those concerns seriously but also
articulate why
i think the cost-benefit analysis is
different than many people who fear this
work
might imagine it to be
from my perspective as a psychologist
so let's actually start i think the
substantive discussion with
the
sociology political politics side of
things i mean what are the kinds of
outcomes what are the situations where
equity and equality arise or or
inequities and inequalities arise that
you care about what what are the what
are the sort of ultimate things we're
trying to connect to the underlying
genetic component
yeah
that's such a good question because i
think we inequality is one of those
words
um that can be used in so many different
ways and
in the the differences in their implicit
meaning can cause people to kind of talk
past each other
at the simplest level i'm just talking
about how do people's lives
end up differently
in
um
goods
that we care about so these can be
material goods things like how much
money you make how much wealth you
accrue over your lifetime
these can be
um what i would consider more
psychological goods like your
opportunity to get an education how much
have you learned
um they can be things like
your subjective well-being so if you
rate you know how how satisfied are you
with your life or my life is the best
possible life i can imagine for me it's
a common way that um people get at just
subject you know people's
one item rating of how well their lives
are going
um we can think about actual lifespan
like how long do you live
um we can think about more psychiatric
things so
um depression suicide
um freedom from
um physical pain
and freedom from psychiatric disorders
and i think what we're seeing right now
pretty uniquely is how
tied up those different inequalities and
outcomes
are with one another so if you look back
in history
you know the wealthiest people
um
they maybe had better food but they
weren't necessarily buffered from
infectious diseases they didn't actually
live that much longer than commoners did
um but if you look now
you know even before the coronavirus
pandemic you're seeing that the
wealthiest americans
were also the most educated
also lived the longest but also reported
the greatest subject of well-being the
greatest freedom from pain they even
report that they like their weekends
more um so you're having all of these
different
um
differences and how people's lives end
up that are really entangled with one
another um and a major axis in which
they they all tend to
um
separate is by education level so the
gap between
people who have a college education
versus don't in all of these different
forms of inequality is large and mostly
getting larger um in the latter half of
the 20th century and into the 21st
that's a really interesting point
because i mean people talk about
wealth inequality it's very easily
measurable right and uh it's growing in
along many measures but the fact that
wealth inequality also correlates with
other kinds of inequality very strongly
so the effect is even bigger than you
might guess is one that i hadn't really
thought about before
yeah so it's not just that people are
you know having more
you know more money to spend on
consumption
um but they have longer to spend it
they're living longer and it seems to be
translating into utility into happiness
in a different way um
so you mentioned that the book touches
on a lot of different subjects and i
think part of the reason why it does you
know why do i end up going into
political philosophy for instance is
that um as a psychologist i think about
okay well i can see these patterns of
correlations in our data um but who are
the people
debating which of these we should take
most seriously what should be our
currency of justice what terms of
inequality do we care about and that
really seems to be the province of
philosophers
well i think that you mentioned
somewhere either in the book or in a
talk uh the work of elizabeth anderson
one of our favorite philosophers and she
was a previous mindscape guest
uh probably the leading person talking
about equality these days and you know
most people enjoyed the podcast etc she
was great but there is just a slice of
people who see the word equality in the
title of a podcast episode
and
assume that you're insisting on equality
of outcomes for everybody that everyone
has the same wealth and the same
education and everything and even though
no one is
asserting that or looking for it
certainly elizabeth sanderson wasn't so
there is some subtlety like you already
said in what we mean by our goals when
it comes to justice and equality and
fairness
yeah and i loved that episode with
elizabeth anderson and thank you i find
her writing
on this to be so lucid and persuasive
and she's been really influential in my
own thinking about this
precisely because i think she
um is offering people
a way out of a kind of tired old
equality of opportunity
by which people often mean treating
everyone exactly the same and you know
whatever results we don't have to care
about
or quality of outcome which also people
use as kind of this um bug bear to be
scared of do we mean like that we're
leveling people down to the same
um uh you know
ident equality meaning identity of
outcome and sameness and
you know something that i found really
interesting about anderson's work as
she's you know she's really thinking
more about what do we mean by
like relational equality how do we
relate to each other's equals
um
she has this really great paper that is
um i might be slightly misrepresenting
the title but it's um it's called human
dignity it's a concept for the economy
and she's really talking about like well
in what ways do we treat people
as equals in the sort of like human
respect sense um which is different from
um making sure that everyone has the
exact same amount of money in their bank
account but it's also different from
you know we're going to treat all people
exactly the same and we don't care about
differences in their life outcomes that
that um that result from there um
so an example that i use in the book is
thinking about
um
uh the american with disabilities act as
an as a as a you know an equal
opportunity legislation um
but
what the americans with disabilities act
is doing is it's not saying
well everyone has the same staircase and
if there's differences in your enjoyment
of the building like we don't have to
care about that right um it's saying we
recognize that there are human
differences and what we're trying to
equalize is people's ability to
participate
in our common public space and i think
that is something
that's really been lost in a lot of the
conversations about educational
inequality
you know when i think about equality
vis-a-vis education
me personally i'm less interested in
equalizing everyone's chances of getting
a phd in physics i'm interested in
how do we equalize people's ability to
participate politically and economically
in a way that makes them feel respected
as equals regardless of their levels of
higher education and i think that's
something that america has really fallen
behind on
what do you best buy wayfair marco polo
and among us have in common
they trust linode as an alternative to
the cost and complexity of the world's
largest public cloud providers linode
makes cloud computing simple affordable
and accessible whether you're working on
a personal project or looking for
someone to manage your company's
infrastructure linode has the pricing
support security and scale you need with
lynnode you get consistent and
predictable pricing across 11 global
markets 24x7 by 365 human support rich
documentation and policies and controls
to strengthen your overall security
posture allowing you to grow at your own
pace
users consistently rank lenode as one of
the leading public cloud providers on
both g2 and trust radius find out why
visit linux.com
mindscape that's
l-i-n-o-d-e dot com slash mindscape and
start a free account today
and something that you emphasize and
anderson also emphasizes is the role of
luck in all of these considerations you
know uh this uh the word meritocracy
appeared in that quote that i that i
started with there is this sort of
american myth or maybe it's a it's a
broader myth than that but the idea that
you know we work hard and we uh deserve
what we get etc etc but the reality is
that in genetics or in other areas of
life
luck has a lot to do with it and uh i
mean maybe say a little bit about you
know how you think about that aspect
because morally it's a tricky thing you
know do we do we take away from people
who just get lucky or do we just live
with that yeah yeah it's such an
interesting
um it's such an interesting rabbit hole
to fall down even just considering
the multiple meanings of the word merit
right so
i think one of the ways that we use it
is
um
you know in this very moral sense right
what we deserve like someone the content
of someone's character like a merit
badge like you've done something to earn
it um and it's an accolade that we give
out
um
you know
as a function of dessert
and then there's a completely
instrumental definition of merit i think
which is um
you know
this is something i've talked about with
my father a lot because he used to be
involved in hiring for fedex he's a
pilot
and there's a number of things that
pilots are hired on that are obviously
unearned right like you have to be not
too short to fit into a cockpit but not
too tall to fit into a cockpit you need
to have correctable vision to 20 20.
these are morally arbitrary human
functionings
um and yet we do think that we should
hire pilots on their merits right which
is you know their ability to fly a plane
well i think what gets so lost in our
discourse about this
is you know people kind of shuffling
back and forth between these two
definitions um
there's a really
wonderful essay
on merit and meritocracy by the
philosopher a marxist sen that i really
appreciate that kind of describes this
this distinction between merit as urn
versus miradis and sermonol
um but i think it affects so much of the
discourse about genetics so this is why
in the book i try to spend a lot of time
talking about the difference between
valuable right something inherently
valuable about a person
versus
um genetics as
associated with traits that are valued
right now given how we've constructed
society um which i i think matches on to
these kind of two different two kind of
working definitions that people have of
merit in their heads and in these
conversations
um i i would say a similar kind of
conceptual confusion surrounds the
phrase equality of opportunity like what
exactly makes opportunity what is
opportunity what makes it equal is also
something that kind of gets
fuzzy in these conversations
well with that groundwork laid let's
talk about the dna let's talk about our
genomes here
so yeah we've been having fun with the
philosophy but let's uh crunch some
numbers and collect some data so uh
what is it for the people out there who
are not experts and i include myself
there what do we measure when we when we
measure what is going on in a person's
genome i mean uh yeah are we looking i
know that the
state of the art is
rapidly advancing more rapidly than keep
up with so are we looking at like
literally the strands of dna and
counting base pairs are we dividing up
into genes and looking at frequencies
what's going on
yeah so i mean i think what's so
interesting is that for you know most of
the history of behavioral genetics we
weren't measuring anything about dna at
all you know the idea of connecting
genetic differences between people the
differences in how their lives turned
out predates anything about our
knowledge
of
you know it predates watson and cricks
it predates the word gene it certainly
predates our ability to measure
something specifically about people's
genes
um and
the opacity of that approach that we
were you know in the era of doing twin
studies or adoption studies
making inferences about the fact that
people's dna made a difference for their
life outcomes without actually measuring
anything about people's dna
may you know contributed to that work
being really controversial
um there's been a huge sea change
with the ability to
sequence and by sequence i mean read
people's dna letters uh
directly right so everyone's genome um
is made up of
a molecule with four what are we called
base pairs gctna and the um
amongst other things people can differ
in
uh their
sequence of dna letters so you might
have a t in one spot whereas i have a g
in that spot
um
so most commonly now what people are
measuring are exactly that these one dna
letter differences between people in
their dna sequence
and those are called single nucleotide
polymorphisms and they're commonly
abbreviated snips
um because of the structure of the
genome part you know chunks of our
genome are sort of co-inherited with one
another
which means that um we
measure a snip but that is quote-unquote
tagging
a number of different variants that are
likely to be co-inherited with that one
variant that you've measured so just
because you've measured that a single
base pair differs from one person to
another so number one let's just pause
and reflect on the fact that it's really
amazing you can measure that one it's
amazing it's so cool it's like you know
i think about that all the time i was
actually just giving a lecture
to a number of graduate students and phd
students and mostly economics and
sociology that are trying to learn about
genetics and
you know i just wanted to pause right
there and be like it is wild right like
it is completely wild and that we can do
it
um that we can do it cheaply right you
know you know we genotype participants
in our lab and it cost us about 55 a
person
um and we can do it non-invasively so
you don't need blood you can use saliva
or you know cheek swabs
and
um i i worked in animal labs when i was
in college sort of like laboriously
doing pcr with with uh rat blood and
it's wild to me how much genetic
information we can get so cheaply and so
easily now compared to to what it what
it used to be i'm glad that you paused
there yeah no i want people to be
impressed by this because it's been
changing a lot and so
but what you just said is provocative
because you're saying that uh we we see
that there is a difference presumably of
one base pair between
this person's dna and this person's dna
but it is associated uh presumably with
extremely high probability with changes
elsewhere so we're not we're not lining
up the two dna strands and measuring
every single base pair on them right
even at this advanced level we're we're
doing something a bit more
coarse-grained than that yes
yeah so there are studies that are
moving towards um you know whole genome
sequencing which is a more fine-grained
read of the entire entire
genome um but most commonly currently
people are using
what are called sniper rays which are
you know um
these these single dna letter
differences that we know are correlated
with other variants that are mostly
nearby on the genome
um and that are reasonably common in the
population by common it's usually like
more than one percent of the population
or more than five percent of the
population um and within that population
we're talking about people who share
recent genetic ancestors so if we're
thinking about like the global pool of
human genetic diversity
um we're missing a lot because we're
missing rare variation and most of our
studies are also missing variation that
is um maybe uncommon or absent in
european ancestry populations but more
common elsewhere um so we're
zooming in on like a pretty
narrow slice of that genetic diversity
and then we're trying to measure it
directly
um and then see if it's um
you know essentially correlated and
we'll get back to how do we get from
coalition to cause maybe later in this
podcast correlated with things we've
measured about people and what we've
measured can be their height or it could
be their how far they went in school or
it could be their income or it could be
their
um glaucoma
um you know pick your phenotype
depending on your discipline probably
we actually had uh joe henrich on the
podcast who makes a big deal about that
okay great the psychology of weird
populations and so you're saying there's
a similar
thing going on in genetics where almost
all of our information is about a tiny
subset of human diversity
oh definitely the genetics of weird
population there's um a sociologist
turned geneticist melinda mills at
oxford whose work is really excellent
and she's published a couple sort of
meta science papers on this um and it's
uh i'm forgetting the statistic but it's
really a shocking amount of what we know
about the genetics of behavior comes
from um uh white people in the uk
iceland and white people in the us so
it's three countries that that
contribute the predominance of our
information here um
so
you know there's real drawbacks to that
because uh
in terms of you know all of science
works on variation and by limiting
ourselves in terms of variation we're
limiting ourselves to what we can find
and many of the problems that um
we see in social science of weird
populations uh is also found in the
genetics of queer populations well
that's good because one of the goals of
mindscape is to let young people who
will eventually be graduate students
know that there's a lot of work
remaining to be done so it sounds like
oh definitely yes
much of the world is remaining to be uh
genetically understood in this way
okay so we can as you said
get a correlation between these features
of someone's dna and uh and what what
are we trying to correlate them with
well you gave some lists but in your
work in particularly yeah so in my work
we've worked um primarily with
um
things related to education so how far
you go to go in school
and then things related to
what psychologists call externalizing
and what economists call risk tolerance
what epidemiologists might call health
risk behavior
which are things like um adhd
conduct disorder uh risk for alcohol
problems um opiate use that sort of
thing so those are the two domains of
gus work genome wide association study
work that my my group has worked on um
and there's you know there's groups it's
it's really actually an amazing
field in terms of being
dominated by this kind of international
team science model so there's teams all
over the world who are you know
attacking various medical phenotypes
psychiatric phenotypes and behavioral
phenotypes so it's uh
right we're already treading into murky
waters here right it's not just height
or 100 percent
it's behaviors and and that's just a
harder thing so you already mentioned
the the sticky issue of there's a
correlation that's easy enough to plot
but the causation is what we care about
i mean what are the kinds of techniques
you use to ask whether or not there is
really a causal relationship between
what you're measuring in the dna and
uh someone's educational attainment for
example
yeah so i think there's kind of two
um major classes of problems in terms of
okay so you've done a study you've
measured these snips in people
and you've done a study of a million
people you've correlated these snips
with something you've measured about
them
you've observed these correlations what
do they mean
so the first class of problems
has to do with what i've already talked
about which is that you're not actually
measuring every single aspect of the
genome and the part of the genome that
you've measured
might be its association might be driven
by another genetic variant that's just
been co-inherited with it um so
that is a problem where people
um
you might basically in the book i say
you know it's like a badly drawn
treasure map right like you know that
like you know the x is in this jungle
but like your aerial view of the jungle
when you're going over it versus like
now you're actually walking through the
jungle trying to find the exact treasure
spot or kind of two different things so
you kind of localize it maybe to a
region of the genome
but you don't know the variance the
causal variant so um a lot of times
people talk about these studies in terms
of
fine mapping studies which are okay i
think it's in this area now i'm going to
measure that part of the genome
more closely more reliably with more
specificity to try to figure out
where in this area is driving the effect
um so that's the kind of first class of
problems the second class of problems is
that people's
genetics are correlated with their
culture right because people
um
you know people have sex with people who
are close to them
um not everyone gets to have sex with
everyone else
repeat over generations and you get um a
genome that is structured by
um a multi-generational history of our
social rules about who has sex with whom
um and so you could see a correlation
between a gene and an outcome that's not
because the gene is causing something in
my biology that's causing the outcome
but just because that gene happens to be
more common in
people from this culture this particular
part of the world
and
they also differ in whatever i'm
studying
for entirely environmental or cultural
reasons
historically people have tried to get at
that problem by
essentially
um trying to
to
use information from across the entire
genome
to estimate what are called principal
components of ancestry which are
basically
um
statistical measures of how similar
people are by virtue of sharing recent
genetic ancestors
and controlling for those in genetic
studies um
so
you know instead of comparing
people who are very diverse in terms of
their genetic background i'm trying to
find people who are fairly homogeneous
in terms of their who their recent
genetic ancestors are
i'm trying to quantify
their similarity based on what i'm
measuring about their genome and then
i'm trying to statistically control for
that
um that's partially successful yeah but
not fully successful
um the best strategy
is
to not try to compare unrelated people
but actually try to compare
family members so the title of the book
is the genetic lottery which is a
metaphor i like for lots of reasons but
one of the reasons is when we're
thinking about
the genetic differences between two
siblings whose parents have the same
genes
the genetic differences between them are
kind of unbraided from that
larger package of culture and
environment and geography
because which genes you happen to
inherit from your parents is random um
and so to really try to get it is it a
genetic cause
versus just
an aspect of the genome that's
correlated with your environment
you need this kind of natural experiment
of
of the fact that your parents could have
given you either one of two copies of
their genius and you happen to get one
and it's that randomness that gives you
some callable purchase
maybe someday in the future we'll live
in a post-scarcity society and then your
company can waste money on inefficient
hiring if it wants to until then save
your money and only pay for quality
candidates on indeed the job site that
makes hiring incredibly simple but
indeed you can attract interview and
hire all in one place you don't just
hope your perfect candidates will find
you with indeed's hiring tools you can
cut through the noise to hire faster and
smarter
indeed's instant match provides a list
of quality candidates whose resumes are
on indeed the moment you post a
sponsored job
indeed knows how important it is to make
the most of your recruiting hours and
dollars so with indeed you save time and
money by setting your must-have
qualifications and only paying for the
quality candidates that meet them so get
started right now with a 75 sponsored
job credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
mindscape get a 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape that's indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through september
30th terms and conditions apply
and i know that in social sciences and
computer science there's been a greatly
improved sophistication in how we think
about causation people like judea pearl
etc
working with bayesian networks and
massive probability distributions like
do you need that level of sophistication
for what you're doing here or is it is
it just we look at the controlled
experiments we we are given access to
and work with what we have
you know i would say like there was
there's kind of no more controversial
word maybe in social science genetics
than cause right the c word cause um
cause and predicts are words that really
get us into trouble
um which is i spend time in the book
uh and a whole chapter in fact as you
know
really defining what i mean by cause so
i think to make sense of this it's not
so much about um
or the sophistication of the analytic
techniques
so much as being very clear about
you know what is a model
of what a cause is that that's kind of
going in to
this type of research
um and and
also what what does that
not entail what is a cause not in this
so
um in this case you know the best thing
that we have access to in humans is this
kind of natural experiment of children
being randomized to genotypes
conditional and their parents genotypes
um
and so it fits really naturally into the
framework of causation that's that's
arisen around kind of like a randomized
control trial right which is really
trying to peek at
the counter factual what would have
happened if you know a cause is a
difference maker essentially
um
what's important about that is that it
doesn't necessarily mean that the
mechanisms are biological it doesn't
necessarily mean that the cause is
deterministic
um you know in social science we think
about cancer causes chansey causes those
chancy difference makers all the time
right
you know does but you know does use of
iphones amongst 12 year olds increase
their risk for depression does not mean
that if you got your 12 year old an
iphone they would necessarily become
depressed
um i think the problem is that it's
difficult for us to take that kind of
chancy and deterministic
average difference maker type of
framework for causes
when we're talking about genes we tend
to pour in a bunch of other assumptions
about what genetic causes are relative
to social science clauses well my wife
jennifer willett actually she's a
science writer and she wrote a book on
the science of self and so she looked a
little bit into these questions and i
remember very vividly how
at least at the at the time because the
state of the art is changing a lot but
they were very very few individual genes
that mapped cleanly onto an actual trait
of a person right yeah earwax
yeah okay good so it's not like you're
looking for a base pair or a gene that
makes you taller makes you live longer
makes you grumpy right it's a it's a
much more subtle kind of nuanced thing
there is no genes for um everything that
we
are looking at here and i think this is
another thing that's hard about thinking
about genetic causes is everything we're
talking about is
polygenic influenced by many many many
many many
genes each of which have a small effect
so when we think about genes influencing
something i think many people think of
like
you know mendel's pea plants like if you
got this version yeah then you were a
wrinkly pea versus a smooth pea
um
uh or kind of like the early 2000s pop
science where people talked about the
gay gene which that you know didn't turn
out to be scientifically accurate at all
instead what we're talking about is
um
you know
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of variants each of which have
minuscule probabilistic effects
but in aggregate add up to something
um that starts to make a difference at a
population at a population level and i
think that that kind of thinking about
a
vast multiplicity of small chancy things
is
different i think than how many people
are originally taught about genetics and
the other complication i'm not sure how
relevant it is here but i know from
previous podcasts and talking to friends
that uh there's not just the genome
there's how it gets expressed right and
yes that's something that could be
environmental as well as genetic
although your parents your mom in
particular do influences is that
something you can keep track of or
control for or is that just a a noise in
your data
um so i mean people definitely do and
our lab also does this kind of work you
know dna is a relatively
inert molecule like i describe it as
like you can have a cookbook that's
sitting on your shelf but that does not
mean you have dinner on the table right
like something has to happen
in order for there to to be you know a
product to be created
and that is very dynamic um
and so there's many different processes
that people talk about in terms of
getting from this genetic
recipe which is you know we can talk
about whether that metaphor is useful or
not
to a protein
dish something that's made
in our lab we look at um for instance
dna methylation which is one kind of
molecular biomarker that's giving you
some information about which parts of
the genome are being expressed
at a certain time in a certain tissue
um what i think is amazing is that
just
essentially despite that despite the
fact that having a gene or genetic
variant doesn't mean that it's being
expressed in your body or in your brain
we nonetheless are seeing these
associations between the just a gene
sequence variation and the things that
we're measuring so
um
part of what makes that relationship
between sequence variation and outcome
probabilistic is this kind of more like
epigenetic
um and environmental interaction that's
happening
and yet on average we still see you know
like that kind of genetic signal coming
through despite all the complexity
that's layered on top of it by the other
levels of our of our biological and
social systems
okay so when we get into the details of
making these these
i i almost want to say predictions but
anyway uh you know identifying
tendencies or chances or
prospects i would say when i was doing
copy edits for my book i went through
and did control f
to look for every instance of the word
predict predicted scrutinized it about
whether or not there was a better word
there so
you can call them predictions but we
should talk about what we mean by that
well yeah good and also we should talk
about how exactly they're made because i
know that at some point um
we talk about the idea of a polygenetic
score right which is somehow taking this
enormous amount of data into dna and
making into one number and predicting
things on the basis of that number so
what is that why is there one number why
would we ever think that one number was
good enough and uh is it just like the
first step toward a future where we're
much more multivariable
yeah so so apologetic score um is you're
right it's one number that aggregates
um kind of our best guess
of your likelihood of showing a
phenotype of showing a particular
outcome
based entirely on information about your
dna sequence
and the way that it's constructed is
that um
researchers
and they might have been a different
group of people or it might have been me
uh
have done a large what are called
discovery studies
where you you know have maybe um 50 000
or 100 000 or a million people
and they have
estimated the correlation between all of
these measured snip genetic variants and
the outcome of interest
and now you have a huge data set that
has
um you know
uh every row is the genetic variant
measured and and the column is the you
know the the
core the estimated correlation between
that genetic variant and let's say
height in this example
and so i take those and i measure dna in
a new group of people
and i use the results of the previous
study
as a way to add up
genetic information on this new group of
people so if they have inherited
um
two copies of this particular snip
from their parents then it would be two
times whatever that estimated
correlation is if they've gotten zero
it'd be zero and then i just literally
sum that up with our
genome
so it's incredibly coarse right i mean
it's it's a huge
[Music]
biologically nonsensical grab bag if you
think about it right so in the case of
education it could be
genes that are correlated because of
this uncontrolled population
stratification it could be genes that
make you
better at doing math it could be genes
that make you more of a morning person
it could be genes that
you know changed your risk of going
through puberty earlier and we know that
girls who go through puberty
are discouraged from in uh more
difficult math classes because they feel
weird and they get more attention from
boys you know it could be any number of
processes
that are all collapsed together into
this one number
um
so i think the question is like well why
would you do that like why would you
make this kind of biological
grab bag
um
one of the and i do think that people
well
you know one way the science will be
moving will be trying to like have less
crude gross kind of crunchy measures
compared to polygenic scores um
one reason that you do that is that even
though each of the individual snips that
go into a polygenic score have these
like infinitesimally small correlations
their aggregation
turns out to be
as strongly correlated with some of the
outcomes that we care about as are other
really gross crunchy variables right so
like if i measure a family's
socioeconomic status you know it's their
education their income their
occupational status
that's also aggregating
a huge number of processes that are
differing between affluent children and
poor children in america
a cacophony of different mechanisms um
but it's telling me something meaningful
about differences in the population and
so i think of really polygenic scores as
being another sort of clunky aggregate
measure like our measures of ses
it's telling us that that people differ
it's allowing us to quantify those
differences but it's
in in buying some
predictive power
you're sacrificing this mechanistic
specificity um
and so i think the challenge then is to
kind of go back and trace out some more
specific mechanisms in many ways
following the arc of social science in
terms of we observed that you know poor
children did worse in school long before
we had uh really clear mechanistic
stories about why
i think i called it a polygenetic score
but that was wrong it was polygenic
scores
you know it's a very common error and i
you know i don't know why like when we
were when we when the field was coming
up with this we just dropped a syllable
it would kind of make more sense for it
to be apologetic score
all right thank you you're being very
kind to me thank you for that thank you
for assuaging my guilt
but just so i'm super clear is the idea
that for every outcome we're interested
we develop a different polygenic score
yes yes so you know a polygenic score
is estimated based on
a set of g watts results that have been
conducted
four different phenotypes so you know if
i calculated your polygenic score quote
unquote four height okay right what is
my best guess of the genetic variants
you have that are statistically
correlated with being taller
that would be different than your
polygenic score
for educational attainment good um
at the same time what we see is that
you know
you might have done
a study of
educational attainment um how many years
have you gone through school which you
know is something that is determined in
your teenage years or your 20s or if
you've gotten a phd sometimes not until
your 30s when you're done with school
um
and that polygenic score quote unquote
for educational attainment
is also associated with you know kind of
all the intermediate spots in that
trajectory of education right so the
educational attainment pleasure in
school isn't just correlated with how
far people go in school but also their
grades in high school and
whether or not
their teacher thought they had attention
problems in elementary school and so you
see
i you know it's it's different for
different domains but i think it's a
mistake to think of a polygenic score as
being too narrowly about the one thing
that research was studying in the
original study but it's just making sure
it's not like you have niq you you have
a polygenics
different polygenic
yeah yeah too bad we could rank people
on their polygenic score that would be
the end of it right then we would just
know how worthwhile people were as human
beings but at the same time you do see
you know you see what are called genetic
correlations and they can sometimes be
surprising and they give us clues right
so if you do a genetic study of height
and then you do a genetic study well
actually i'll give you a real example
like if you do a genetic study of
um educational attainment and then you
do a genetic study of uh schizophrenia
you end up with some of the same genes
and some of them work in the same
direction from an opposite and that has
actually turned out to be like kind of a
puzzle for researchers um
to figure out so
i think in in academia we we like our
neat
silos right that the medical geneticists
study
medical phenotypes like lung cancer
and the psychologists study
you know maybe nicotine addiction
and the economist study
uh
labor markets
but in real life those things go
together you know your success on the
labor market and your likelihood of
smoking and your likelihood of
developing lung cancer and so as a
result of life being messy the genetics
are messy too you get some of the same
genetic associations for things that
people think of as being in very kind of
different camps medical versus
behavioral
there are some things you just can't do
at home from seeing live music to hiking
your favorite trail what you can do is
exercise with peloton you'll have a
workout experience like no other without
ever leaving home what i like best about
peloton is the convenience not just of
the time of day when you're working out
but the type of workout that you're
getting maybe you're in the mood for
just cardio or maybe you want something
that gets you strength training as well
peloton can give you yoga pilates
outdoor runs meditation and more and
with epic artist collaborations and
instructor curated playlists peloton's
music experience is unlike any other
whether you're in the mood for hip-hop
pop or country the peloton bike has the
right music to keep you entertained and
motivated all year long with the peloton
bike there's nothing like working out
from home learn more at onepeloton.com
new members can try peloton classes free
for 30 days at
onepeloton.com app terms apply that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
well also my impression is that some of
the things that you're correlating with
are things like the probability of
becoming homeless
uh and
if we if we say that there's a genetic
relationship
sorry let's back up uh the idea of a
home wasn't invented when the gene was
invented so
if you say that there's a genetic
relationship between a relationship
between your genes and let's say the
proclivity for mental illness or the um
susceptibility to become a drug addict
uh
that that's you can sort of see the
causal path in your mind whereas the
causal path to homelessness is a bit
removed so i mean how sneaky do you have
to be when you even contemplate
correlating dna information with
outcomes like homelessness or getting a
phd or something like that i mean there
must be a million confounding variables
in the way
yes well i mean i think
you know i use the example of
homelessness in the book um really
because i'm trying to
give a vivid example of something that
is is obviously a social problem that is
responsive to local social policies like
here in austin we've had this
huge debate about criminalizing camping
for
um
unhoused populations and so there's very
large homeless encampments um under
freeways for about two years and then
the
uh the repeal and the camping ban was
unrepealed and so now it's criminalized
again so it's clearly a social problem
that we deal with with social policy
and within a society not everyone is
equally likely
to become homeless
and the sorts of
um
vulnerabilities that set you up for risk
things like mental illness things like
doing poorly in school you know
ultimately
you know as i say in the book not being
homeless is being unable to afford
housing right it is about like an
intersection of
you know
how you've exchanged your skills for
money in the labor market and like the
affordable housing in your in your
society so i use that example because um
you know i'm really trying to make a
point about how
we
our biology is affecting kind of our
embodied traits right and that might be
like a temperamental thing or that might
be like our risk for serious mental
illness
and then those embodied traits are are
refracted through
this political economic social contacts
um
in ways that matter right like in ways
that like we see we see when we're
driving around
and
um
both as a scientist but also as someone
who's you know trying to kind of make
sense of my moral responsibilities in a
complex world
um i really want to think about that
whole picture both
you know how what can we understand
about
why some people are are born with a
higher risk of becoming schizophrenic
than other people which i actually don't
think is a very controversial statement
um
and then
how does society
act on those embodied differences in
ways that create these forms of social
inequality
um so from a scientific perspective
you know it seems like such a strange
thing to
at first maybe a counterintuitive thing
to connect
dna to income right like income is
clearly social right
but if we observe genetic patterns that
are correlated with income
what is that telling us about about
which
embodied characteristics and which
skills are being rewarded and which
aren't in the way that we've currently
constructed the social system um
so i think when geos first started we
you know baby people thought we would
have like really nice pretty biological
proximate phenotypes to study
um but it turns out that the things that
we collect data on on like a million
people is how far they've gone to school
and whether or not they own their home
and so we're actually kind of working
backwards um
not where it was like
we've jumped like eight eight levels of
analysis
and now how can we use those
associations to kind of kind of you know
as a kind of trail of breadcrumbs to
follow back to figure out like what are
the intervening processes here can we
give the listeners some
intuition for this
quantitative size of these effects like
if you if you are able to map out
someone's genome very effectively
to what extent does that predict
something like income or educational
attainment is a one percent effect is it
almost all of it uh
what what variables
it's such a good question and i think
part of the reason why it's such a good
question is because the tools that
scientists use at least social
scientists use
to quantify effect size you know most
commonly something like an r squared
which is a percent variation accounted
for
um
you know we we often don't have a good
intuition for how the
relationships that we see play out
around us would be quantified on that
kind of r squared metric so just to kind
of put put so some more concrete numbers
on it
you know if you look at
um
uh
americans and you want to say okay
there's all this variation and whether
or not someone completes college
we know that affluent children are more
likely to complete college than children
raised in less affluent families
what is the percent variation accounted
for and college completion rates
by family income right and zero would be
everyone has an equal chance of
graduating from college regardless of
their family income and one would be i
can predict with absolute certainty your
risk of you know your rate of polish
completion your likelihood of college
completion by knowing how much
money your parents made
so the best estimates for that in the us
today are around 11 to 15 percent okay
so sorry for what for what for a family
income and rate of college completion so
right so like when we look around and we
say the the relationship we observe
between
being richer and being more likely to
complete college is about let's let's
round up let's say around 15
of the variation
so that's 85 that's not related to that
right which we can also we know rich
kids who slacked off in school and we
know
um kids who raised their poor families
who did really really well
um any college professor can look at the
vast you know i teach at ut and my
students come from a vast
vastly different economic circumstances
and i can see that students
who are coming from poor families have
more challenges um but i also know that
it does it's not destiny it's not
deterministic
um so that is about the same effect size
that we see for a polygenic score in
relation to
completing college
so
you know i know about as much about a
person's chance of graduating from
college if i know their political score
if they're
um
of european genetic ancestry and so
likely to identify as white and that's a
very important caveat
um as i would from knowing uh how much
money their parents made and you know in
the years before they went off to school
um so is that a big effect size or a
small effect size i think that depends
on
your
your
you know what are you trying to do am i
trying to make forecasts about this
person's fate then it's not very good
yeah am i trying to explain
the broad dynamics of how people in
american society differ in a really key
outcome in their life then i then i do
think that matters um and so it's that
kind of middle middle ground
of it's neither i don't think it's a you
know i don't think it's genetic
astrology i don't think it's worthless
but i don't think it's deterministic
either it's in between
well and the next obvious question then
is if you know
both their polygenic score and their
family's income does that make you
predict things better or is it kind of
redundant
yeah so it's you know it's not redundant
information
which um you know really common question
is like why would we do
genetics when we can do with the
environment and you know i think that's
kind of kind of a false
either or
this is not
the layer of information about someone
this is not the most important layer of
information about someone but it's an
additional layer of information about
someone that's telling us something that
would be otherwise hard to quantify and
see and that's giving us kind of a new
ability to capture variation um in
um
in people's lives and we see that
non-redundancy even if we're looking at
other levels of analysis so for instance
you know i can say
what do i know about you if i know your
apologetic score above your
socioeconomic status
um but i can also say well what's the
average ses in this school what's the
concentration of of
affluent or poor children in this high
school
what's the average polygenic score in
the school and those are correlated but
only at around you know 0.4.5 right so
even our our sense of
how students are clustered in different
educational contexts we get this kind of
different
um piece of information about that too
well let me ask basically the same
question except instead of considering
completely external factors consider
things we can measure about people other
than their genetics right so yeah so the
example i have in mind i think i think
this is in your book again uh i think
you call it the leaky genetic pipeline
where
if you know certain things about
people's polygenic scores then you can
you can predict whether or not they will
keep taking math classes right you know
later later in school and uh that's
completely plausible to me but also i
remember you know when i was in junior
high school i would have been able to
predict pretty well which of my
classmates would have gone on to take
the higher math classes and which ones
wouldn't have so in that case i mean
just from talking to people getting an
impression of what they're like thinking
about their
test scores and their grades and and
things like that is is the genetic
information still
new or is it redundant with that kind of
thing
so i think it's still new
um
and then and i would say in three
different respects so the specific study
that you're talking about is when we are
looking at
a sample of american high school
students and we're looking at which math
class were they tracked to in the ninth
grade
and then
um
how did they move through the math
curriculum over the course of high
school this was in the 1990s when math
was only compulsory for about two years
in most u.s states so you could take
algebra and then geometry and then drop
out or you could take geometry and
algebra 2 and precalculus and calculus
and that's actually the modal route
taken by most
of science phds probably some people
took calculus in high school
um and so what we saw is that the
educational attainment polygenic score
predicted both
and by predict i mean it captured
non-negligible variation in
which math class people were assigned to
in the ninth grade and their likelihood
of dropping out um
from year to year
what's interesting about that analysis
is the polygon explorer predicted math
dropout even controlling for people's
grades in their previous math class so
if you're thinking about like an
observable characteristic that a school
district would have or a local high
school would have yeah you're looking at
kids who both have made b pluses in
their geometry class
um and who both have the same level of
family sex
and the polygenic score is still
predicting which one drops out of math
versus not so i think that speaks to the
pow the potential power of some genetic
measures in some genetic contexts in
some research contacts
having some you know extra bang for our
box it's giving us information that
would be hard to see
just from say someone's transcript
the other thing that's that's
interesting about the dna measures is
that they have two
special characteristics
that most psychological characteristics
don't have like test scores or self you
know self-reported interest in taking
math
and the first is that
your dna sequence doesn't change
its association with things might change
but it doesn't change itself it's not
reciprocally
affected by
the experiences that you're
going through in your life
so
um you know one metaphor my colleagues
and i often use is you know if you are
going to like a radiologist and they're
doing an imaging study they give you a
molecular tracer
that
um is not metabolized the way that your
body usually metabolizes something if
you drink drink it
so that you can see the structure right
it's inertness is what allows you to see
the structure that that moves through
because it's not being changed by the
structure and that is something that's
very hard to come by with any of our
normal psychological variables um our my
interest in math is affected by whether
or not i have a shitty math teacher last
year but my dna sequence is not
um and the second characteristic that it
has is that
and again this is a very important
caveat conditional on your parents
genetics
my your genetics is randomly assigned
right so conditional on your you know
knowing your parents dna
which dna you have
is
random
and we have almost no variables like
that
uh in observational social science right
so there's nothing there's nothing about
someone's test scores or self-reported
interest or motivation
then i can say
if i measure something about your
parents i can treat variation in this as
you know reasonably exogenous to other
things like as randomly assigned and and
that allows for a different set of
analyses and inferences about what's
causing what um
so i think it's just a repeat that you
know you're getting observing predictive
power over things you ordinarily measure
and it's inert temporally
and it's randomly assigned contention on
parents okay yeah that is extremely
helpful so
what are we gonna do with it
other than just you know uh judge people
um you know i mean and part of the
reason why it's a tricky question right
is because
people do sort of count things
redundantly like if they think that you
know a certain group is unlikely to be
good at math but one person within that
group
turns out to be really good at math
there are those who will still judge
them negatively like you can't be good
at math you're in that group right so so
how can we flip that script a little bit
and and use this new information to help
people like you say uh achieve what
they're capable of achieving and live
the lives that we would like them to be
able to live yeah
you know you started off this interview
by reading the very um very like
eloquent pithy uh publisher copy uh that
my that princeton university press wrote
for my book and i think it's a good
thing that they you know they wrote it
because i think if i wrote it it would
probably be something like
you know paige harden wants to make
genetics boring
and what i mean by that is you know my
goal would be
for genetics to be you know using
polygenic scores or
um
incorporating siblings or twin designs
as part of your research
to become a really really routine part
of
kind of the everyday workings of
developmental clinical and educational
psychologists you know like i want it to
be like
propensity square matching or
instrumental variables analysis like you
know a routine technique that we
that we teach to refine the rigor of
someone's inferences
and i think
if we did that
we could do a lot better
more quickly
at
identifying
bright spots identifying the features of
people's environments
particularly of children's environments
that are
most efficacious at actually producing
the outcomes that a psychologist we say
we want to produce produces outcomes in
children
so
currently
you know all social scientists
are really faced with this problem of
like messy free-range humans are hard to
do experiments with and everything's
correlated with everything else
and we can look to our data and we can
say
you know
um
parents who eat dinner as a family by 5
30 p.m have kids that do better in
school
but that doesn't tell us that actually
intervening on family dinner time would
actually be the best most cost-effective
way of of improving children's academic
performance and that's kind of a silly
example of family dinner but that is
actually the case with you know almost
all the variables we study
um and genetics gives us another way
of saying
how are people who are
similar in this one measured capacity
but who have happened to find themselves
in different environments
how do they differ
so that we can identify
what are the
most promising environmental levers for
change that's what i want people to do
with genetics um you know
a lot of times people are like well i'm
not interested in genes and i'm like
yeah but you're interested in kids yeah
and kids outcomes get their genes from
the same people who give them their
environments so if you're interested in
kids and you're interested in figuring
out which environments help kids succeed
you kind of have to be a little bit
interested in genes if only to get it
out of the way from messing up what
you're trying to do
the obvious analogy which maybe i got
from your book and i'm now forgetting
but uh if there were a gene that said
that you're much more susceptible to
sudden heart attacks but it's
preventable if you do the right thing
yeah then of course you'd want to know
whether or not you were susceptible to
that so you could prevent it and
presumably there are similar stories to
be told about oh this student would
benefit from this kind of educational
environment or plan or something like
that that we can learn hope ideally the
goal would be that we could learn from
their genetic information
and i think even you know people often
go you know when they're thinking about
kind of like that um
heterogeneity in people's outcomes and
kind of matching people to interventions
it's easy to go straight to where you
went which is like kind of the more
personalized medicine route or the more
personalized education wrote like can we
use this to identify people who are like
very at risk for outcomes for poor
outcomes i think there's a more basic
level even before we get there
which is that
we know in
almost all
randomized control trials of
psychological or educational
interventions
that there are vast differences between
people and how they respond to that
intervention right so if i
you know i used to be a practicing
therapist i'm not anymore but if someone
comes to me for therapy and i say okay
we're gonna do cvt for depression
you know some people respond to that and
some people don't um if you do a
tutoring program that has a small
average treatment effect
for kids math skills
that small average treatment effect can
mask enormous range and some kids been
offending hugely and some not at all
um
often what you see in educational
interventions and psychological
interventions is what we call a matthew
effect in which
not only is there variation in how
people respond but it's the people who
are least at risk that get the most help
right it's the students who are already
doing well who benefit the fastest it's
the fact that rich kids learn more
vocabulary from sesame street than poor
kids do
um
so i think
even if we don't start matching kids to
interventions just knowing where there
are current slate of interventions
who is being served by those um you know
are we helping people who are most at
risk for poor outcomes or are we helping
people who are you know is it a rich get
richer effect
those sorts of heterogeneity studies can
be really difficult to do
and genetics doesn't solve all the
problems but by adding this another
layer of information particularly the
labor information that's again invariant
like it you know your dna sequence can't
be changed by the intervention
um i think we can have a better tool for
seeing
who is being served
by which of our policies and
interventions just knowing that i think
would be useful information like if we
you know if we could know like this um
you know statin drug
uh it works on average but like it
really doesn't work for people who are
most at genetic risk for heart attacks
so we would consider that a problem like
we would want to know that
um i think it's the same thing for okay
well this educational intervention
it works on average but for the people
who are most you know
from what we can see from their genetics
are most at risk for bad outcomes ah it
does it's not serving them like why why
wouldn't we want to know that
information
and can we bring this back to the notion
of the lottery and luck uh i mean
yes our genes are in some sense random
so what does this teach us about the
question of what do we do about that or
how how do we conceptualize that you
know i mean do we do does it change the
way in which we assign uh merit or
achievement to people
i mean i think that's a difficult
question because
it is the time i don't think the science
commits
commits anyone to a certain set of moral
or political beliefs sure
um
you know i think people
people can take that information that
observation about the world the people
are born different in ways that matter
for their lives
um
uh and run with that in lots of
different directions
you know for me personally it's helped
me
clarify
some of my intuitions about what makes
a social structure or society
good like when i think about a good
society or a just society
i'm thinking about one
um
that
is
you know more like a meadow and less
like a monoculture one in which people
who have
you know genetic diversity
um can all have a place to thrive and
participate
um
and not a place in which
you know
one genetically influenced set of skills
and traits
and
is favored to the expense of everyone
else um
so
it's just thinking about the
arbitrariness of um
you know what i've passed on to my own
kids what kind of society do i want to
leave for them in their difference and
their genetic difference
um and how i think that's that's really
intuitive for parents you know they
might look at their own kids and they
can see how they're different from one
another and they want structures like
their schools and their neighborhoods
that accommodate those differences and
allow both
you know all of their children to
succeed
um i you know
thinking about
social justice i know that's a freighted
word social justice from that
perspective that a just society
is one
that kind of scales up that vision of
accommodation of difference that i would
want for my own family um
that's a big part of what i'm trying to
articulate in this book yeah no i think
it's a very good vision but we're past
the hour mark at the podcast now so
we're allowed to let our hair down a
little bit and
the crazier questions um we'll we'll go
back to that very articulate thing you
just said but
you know okay if i think about other
podcasts i've done like with fidor ornov
who's an expert on crispr and so forth
when are we gonna reach the point where
we just identify the bad genes and fix
them before they get propagated down to
the next generation right and then
everyone will be smart and beautiful
um
wow there's so much in that question
there
i think you know
there's a couple things i want to
respond to and first is it's back to
this
small effect size right so
you know even leaving aside something as
controversial as educational payment or
income like if you just want to crisper
your baby to be taller
yeah that would be there's not a gene
that's going to do that for you right
like the stuff that's being identified
is again thousands or hundreds of
thousands of genetic variants and so no
one is really talking about crispr in
that context they might be thinking of
talking about um you know egg selection
for egg donation or embryo selection
um where you're selecting a polygenic
score but that's a different context
than crispr which is i think really more
about these more
um
monogenic you know single locus
variations of large effect um at least
to my understanding of it i don't think
anyone's really proposing crispering 100
000 variants in your genome at this
point in time
um
the second thing is this this idea of
good gene and bad gene
um
we have socially valued traits and
socially dis valued traits
and the genetics don't really conform
all the time to our really our our
intuitions about that so going back to
that example of education and
schizophrenia if you have a genetic
variant that makes it more likely for
you to get a sim phd but also more
likely to become schizophrenic is that a
good gene or a bad gene you know i don't
think we have a sense of that
you know the classic example is
um you know if you have one copy of this
gene you're more resistant to malaria if
you have two sickle cell disease right
like is that a good gene or a bad gene
um so i think that
you know part of there's a lot of
different ways that we can define
eugenics
um but eugenics literally means you know
good genes that's projecting our social
values
you know down into the biology which i
think
um our bio our biology tends to confound
those kind of neat distinctions that we
have
um
so those are the major things that i
that that i would respond to about that
and then i you know going back to what i
said earlier about
you know i want a society that's a you
know a meadow not a monoculture um
you know when i think about
this idea of like everyone being smart
and beautiful like
smart in the way that
physicist phds are smart like i actually
think that would be a really really
boring culture if everyone was smart in
that particular way i would vote against
that don't worry
beautiful in the sense that runway
models are beautiful um i you know if
you think about like our revealed
preferences like where do people often
want to live and where vibrant
communities there it's not communities
in which everyone is like kind of uh
narrowly phenotypically the same sure
i guess i mean the reason why i ask you
most mostly ingest i don't think that uh
i'm not advocating for
making sure everyone is is smart and
beautiful but
i kind of think because it is very
complicated whenever you talk to the
biologists about this they will
instantly say look it's much more
complicated than you think you're not
going to be able to go in there and
tinker with dna and get the babies you
want it just doesn't work that way
but i also think people are going to try
uh you know
sure
people don't want to live in a
monoculture
but if you ask them do they want their
babies to be smart and beautiful they're
gonna say yes
and uh i i don't know what to do about
that i mean i don't know
what the social policy should be and i
think that you know the the
this the scientific impulse to say look
it's much more complicated you than you
think is going to run up into the
untrained impulse to say i'm going to do
it anyway right we already see that
happening
yeah i mean i agree with you about that
you know i think we've already seen
evidence of that and
direct to consumer genetic testing
companies where it's you know we're
going to match you to your you know the
the wine that you're going to like the
most or your spotify playlist based on
your dna and that's obviously a
scientific but that doesn't mean that
there aren't consumers for it
there's a couple of different
conflicting intuitions here
um
you know one thing that i i want to make
salient
that i think is often lost in this
conversations is that
um
for me personally
um
i value women having
autonomy over their reproductive choices
even reproductive choices that i don't
agree with for personal reasons and i
think that that value needs to be
salient in all of our conversations
about
um the uses of reproductive technology
um
you know not losing sight of the fact
that like
there are women who are making choices
about their bodies and the babies that
they bring into the world and that needs
to be i just i just kind of want to
center that as a consideration
um it's also interesting for me because
you know i live in
a fairly conservative part of the world
and my own experiences being pregnant
have been
that even
um
routine genetic testing that's not
controversial amongst the scientific
community is approached with a great
great delicacy
um because you know many
women where i live in texas um
uh don't agree with the idea of any sort
of prenatal genetic testing like when i
was pregnant with my first child i
remember my ob
um was suggesting that i do like the
standard 20-week scan to see if there's
any sort of fetal abnormalities um and
then she was like and then if there is
we could get you know a genetic test
based on this and she said it's so
delicately as if i was going to be
offended like by the idea yeah of you
know the genetic testing and so i think
oftentimes our conversations
around
um
you know people adopting embryo
selection
seem to me a little bit divorced from
uh the other aspects of how like sort of
reproductive politics play out in this
country in which there are a lot of
women who are really really skeptical of
anything that that that smacks of that
so that's not so much an answer it's
just like a response of like two factors
that i think are often lost
in conversations around this topic no i
think that i'm very glad you said those
things because even though i am trying
to be provocative about the the gattaca
future that we that we're walking into i
mean like you say there are much more
direct and immediate issues that we have
to worry about we can get distracted by
some of these other you know shiny
things to worry about i think they're
important i want to worry on all
landscapes
and that's just i mean i think it's a
good question you know the the
i don't think it's being distracted
about the galactic future i you know
my ultimate goal would be to try to
empower as many women as possible with
as much accurate science about what the
genetics is that isn't aren't is and
isn't saying about what they can do with
these reproductive choices um but also
honor their autonomy in making those
choices that would be my personal sort
of like
broad brushstrokes approach to thinking
about this problem and i can't think of
any other better place to end than that
that's an extremely admirable goal so
paige hardin thanks so much for being on
the mindscape podcast thank you so much
for having me this is a great
conversation
[Music]
you